trauma and everybody keeps on blaming
everything nowadays on trauma
but if I can have counseling and
cognitive therapy back in the 80s and
90s it's available out there for
everybody and more women especially
women
they need to start going and getting
therapy because I'm I'm sick and tired
of hearing about people's trauma
nowadays I've got to the point where
I've had much from within you I don't
care about yours because you're wearing
it like a badge you know like oh I'm
doing this because I've got this trauma
come on nobody's had if I wanted to
nobody in their life has had more trauma
than I have I wear my healing as my
badge as soon as you as soon as you get
like you get grapes go and get
counseling I did I got abused go and get
counseling that counseling didn't work
go and get one that works for me and
that's what I did I don't carry around
baggage I do with it and I leave it and
I move on as a whole human being I'm not
going to turn around and say oh it was a
great victim and and
no can I just say something I'm sick and
tired of hearing about people's trauma I
don't care about nobody's trauma
definitely deal with it can I just say
something do you know who also needs a
lot of therapy demand them too because
men carry a lot of trauma they don't
talk about it so actually they become a
lot of the victims that deal with things
that's in the like quietly and then they
start hurting other people too it's not
just the women women need men need um
therapy too but the whole point is that
when men have trauma they use their
penises and vaginas to get rid of their
trauma and guess what then it's gone and
then they get the girls that don't want
to have babies pregnant
that is why when the women have issues
before they go and sleep with these kind
of men
that's why they need to have them
because people are saying oh um I came
from a single parent family that Mama I
was raising my Mom and Dad my mom and
dad got divorced and my mum raised me on
her own and I I've got Trauma from then
have I got trauma no oh my parents sent
me to um
um Africa when I was a child and I've
got trauma I got sent to Barbados have I
got trauma no I got sent away from my
parents for to go to school have I got
trauma no I'm sick and tired I got
graped so did I they ain't reported it
I've done it I got I reported it
you know it's got to the point where I
get sick of watching certain programs
especially stupid programs like
EastEnders and and and Emmerdale because
something would happen at the end of it
if you're affected by this program
please phone this number you know and
then you have people saying oh I got
graped and I was watching this program
and it brought it all back to me did you
find the number at the end no because
you like are you enjoying your pain some
women enjoy that pain it around it's a
trophy nowadays it's part of like um
everyone uses these kind of identity
topics as a way of as an honor right
like a feminist or most feminist I've
met will have some kind of trauma like
this and they they talk about therapy
they'll never use it and they'll keep on
doing the same dumb stuff because it's
like a you know but um on that point the
initial question was I wouldn't date
someone who who had an abortion just
because in my experience I'm pro-choice
but I've seen it's extremely traumatic
and like those women are never the same
again that's one thing people don't tell
you people people are likely just having
a voice but those women those women like
it does mess you up and I think it's
abortion is a horrible horrible thing
and I think it should be avoided at all
costs yeah this is the thing like and
like I said you have to you have to deal
with the consequence I'm not gonna lie
one of the things I agree with Auntie
for sure people tend to be very mentally
weak and that goes on both sides women
and men that's why I said men need
therapies all their weakness is just
displayed in different ways because at
the end of the day if you're going to
make that decision you make it logically
as well if you even make it emotionally
there's there's logic behind your
emotion that's why therapy works because
there's a certain logic so if you're
logical about it you get over it so
instead of you thinking about I wouldn't
be with a girl that doesn't that has had
an abortion maybe start thinking I
wouldn't be with somebody that is
unhealed because everybody goes through
everything you're just healing you grow
from no I think I think it just I think
it just says that you're selfish because
because you're thinking because you're
thinking of yourself before the child
and like and the thing about the child
trust me my sister I could be a mother
anytime I believe I'll be a great mother
however I believe that I I would prefer
to put my child in a situation where I
know you're not going to be abused
because the father is just right but
then like women that are actually
selfless will leave that situation and
figure out a way to to raise them they
don't just say oh me me me me I'm first
yeah and there's some women are selfless
but they still don't know what they're
doing and they end up ruining the
child's life
because they they have fatherless again
again so that that happened sure but
usually those women are selfish too
because I'm sorry you can't like like
the women of my my moms and like older
generation they don't do this [ __ ] all
around the freaking world man it's just
here
um by the way just one thing about this
conference just to take it up one level
one thing I always find frustrating
about this conversation and I've
discussed this many many times over the
years with people of course I have
strong feelings I know the pro-life pop
position is not the most popular one in
the modern Western World
um but I believe it's the correct one
and one thing that's always frustrating
about these conversations is people both
men and women act like we don't know how
babies are made
right there's very little talk about
personal responsibility self-control
discipline making wise decisions it's
just do whatever you want the truth is
Society wants people to just to be able
to just do whatever have sex with
whatever whoever don't think about it
and you no have no consequences you can
always you know get rid of the evidence
that's what the truth is where you know
when people are jumping to these very
rare cases extreme cases of incest or
extreme cases of of grape and so on and
so forth they're really distracting from
99 of the issue and I wish people could
just be more honest about it and we
could have that talk about
responsibility and proper sexual
behavior and being being careful being
cautious making better wiser decisions
less democracy Upstream so that we're
now we're not dealing with I think I
think people regardless of the different
positions here hopefully I think we'd
all agree that ideally
things should not even get to that
situation right and the truth is we have
we have so many ways now let's be real
we have so many ways to avoid that we've
got guys here who are in their in their
30s you know you've managed to make it
through without having a kid and getting
anyone pregnant and so on it's it's not
it's not impossible it's not rocket
science but you do have to be careful
and make wise decisions can I just give
you a scenario what if yeah you mean to
go on a night out you use protection the
condom breaks you don't know this girl I
wouldn't have sex with a girl I don't
know listen
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible